joining me now is wisconsin congressman
tom tiffany who was also trying to sound
the alarm on this last year congressman
this is what the white house was telling
us last september watch this
i can absolutely assure you that no one
is coming into the united states of
america who has not been through a
thorough screening and background check
process
congressman what a difference 13 months
make but you and i were on to this from
the beginning
yeah should it be any surprise to the
american people that they were misled
this is no different than the southern
border when majorca secretary marcus
came before the judiciary committee and
lied to us and said the border is secure
a year ago president biden said
inflation is transitory and now uh a
year later we find out that they did not
vet them and as you said laura we were
talking about this a year ago i was at
fort mccoy here in wisconsin we saw the
first two thousand refugees come in none
of them had went through the siv process
i asked about it people could walk right
off from the base without
any authorization from the commanding
officer we sounded the warning bell on
that and now finally the inspector
general of the department of homeland
security is talking about this and
saying
this is a threat to national security
and to our local communities yeah
basically it's one big oops except but
potentially the lives of american
citizens are going to be jeopardized
because of this
thirst or
desperate desire to bring more refugees
into a country uh now congressman
earlier this year you shared a link
i believe it was on your twitter account
of a report of this pentagon audit
of this entire vetting process and you
wrote that the bite administration has
been recklessly releasing potentially
dangerous afghans into our communities
well the liars and the propagandists of
politifact said that your comments were
mostly false
the fact checkers are basically just a
pr you know arm of the democrats at this
point
yeah for sure well uh we sent notice to
him today and we said we hope you update
your political act because now it is
very clear as you said the department of
defense has identified this and now the
department of homeland security
inspector general has identified this
also and i think a key point here and
i've been saying this from the very
start over a year ago laura
they should have to go through the siv
the special immigrant visa process if
they would have went through the process
just like the previous administration we
wouldn't have these questions at this
point afghanistan is a completely
different country you don't go down to
the dmv in kabul and figure out who
people are that's not how it
that's now and how it works in
afghanistan yeah are all of them
interpreters
i guess that's a lot of interpreters
congressman thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else